makes sense but don't you think that if
he had actually played Knight takes H3
black really pushes that right black
absolutely pushes that there was an
intermetzo where Black's Knight on F2
could have captured the H3 Pawn with
check it would have been a three onone I
think Karu sees it he's shaking his head
why is he shaking his head I think he
realizes there was a little Mutual
blunder there at the end of the game but
the fact remains a draw in game one what
else could we have expected other than a
sharp even game Amon of course that's
what we got and of course it wasn't just
like oh yada yada let's trade all the
pieces make a draw it's like no uh we
actually saw he cared down to 10 20
seconds we saw a piece sacrifice we saw
two pieces for a rook we saw a lot and
it ended up in stalemate and I would
caution people in the chat about making
you know conclusions on the basis of the
first game the players are still
settling in there's still testing each
other's opening preparations even for
Hikaru and Magnus there is a period of
adjustment where you have to settle the
butterflies in your stomach and I think
they did a great job of doing that
overall I think we're going to see
Hikaru playing a little bit faster in
subsequent games although as I say that
he is taking his time in this second
game also a Ru Lopez this one a little
bit different but largely a similar
structure yeah and it's such a such an
interesting concept uh Daniel what what
would be your like you know 30second
explanation for why you would bring a
bishop out to develop in Castle and then
and bring it literally back to the
starting square like how can you make
that make sense I think what people need
to understand is that open and closed
positions operate very differently this
is still a closed Center position and as
long as the center remains closed the
value of each individual Tempo is
greatly reduced you can often afford to
make more than one move with each piece
and that doesn't necessarily completely
change the dynamic of the position black
is still very fundamentally sound and
there's the answer to our question Aman
G6 by Magnus redeploying the bishop on
G7 why in order to protect the king and
to exert long-term pressure on White's
D4
pawn and NAA with so NAA is with the
black pieces here unless I have it
backwards just confirming no he does
have black okay just making sure um but
Bishop to G7 and it looks like we're
going to see this Knight G3 maybe I mean
maybe just a slow moving game you know
what's interesting is this is the same
structure as a king's Indian but it's
vastly different in the sense that Rook
E8 you're not playing F5 and going for
that oh you know F4 G5 G4 I don't think
we'll see any of that so it's going to
be much more Central play and another
big question how is white going to Res
is white going to resolve the tension in
the center if so there are two ways to
do it white could play D5 and then the
game does take on a More Kings Indian
flavor and we actually might potentially
see black dropping the Knight away from
F6 and trying to push the F Pawn
although I agree I think it's very
unlikely but I think the likelier
scenario is for white to take on E5 and
open that Center up uh and then try to
massage those squares in the center get
the Knight not to G3 but maybe to E3 and
eventually to D5 Magnus though he keeps
the tension gets it to G3 how is he
going to continue are we going to see
those kg A4 Bishop D2 moves just trying
to keep the tension exert as much
pressure as possible yeah I feel like
these are the kind of games where you
see Queen C1 and you're like oh yeah
that's a really really impressive move
I I honestly think your speech about
Tempe is so relevant here you were
talking earlier about how closed
positions the value of individual Tempe
is not as high and look at this we see
moves like Queen f8 Rook d8 there's
nothing that has been captured yet Danel
incredible still nothing that's been
captured and hikaro literally begging
mag please open up the defile so that I
can Target your queen on D2 look at that
standoff between Black's rook and
White's Queen and this greatly increases
the probability that Magnus plays D5 but
still he keeps the tension it's reached
its peak amazing amazing look at this
like I don't know how you want go D5
especially because it kind of traps the
Knight like Knight C6 can't happen and
Knight B7 to d8 to where sorry B5 really
does make sense but soon as you close
the position Dan then the move F5
becomes a real idea for uh Hikaru
especially with that Queen almost posing
as a rook on f8 man that Knight on A5
reminds me of having to fly to all those
remote locations for the world youth
Chess Championship I'd go like San
Francisco to Istanbul then you'd fly to
some small Turkish city then you'd hop
on a bus and go four hours and then get
a taxi that you would have to share to
the hotel that night is a long journey
back to civilization but look at Magnus
keeps the tension shifts his Queen from
D2 to E2 why I think he's eyeing that A6
Square actually because Hikaru has
shuttled all of his pieces to the center
and the King side and finally we get a
release a partial I should say release
of the tension as hearu trades once
drops his Knight back to C6 and where is
that Knight going from C6 that's been a
key Narrative of on if you go to B4
after Bishop B1 white will be
threatening A3 and the Knight is finally
trapped on B4
truly yeah for the first time we finally
see the move D5 committed but a little
bit different now Knight E5 played and
we might see I was about to say we might
see actually Knight D2 with the idea of
f4 but he actually takes right
away okay and Rook takes E5 will likely
be met with F2 F4 although you don't
want to play F4 without careful
consideration because in the long run
the E4 Pawn is weak and an idea that we
shouldn't neglect him on is H5 H4
targeting the Knight on G3 and softening
up White's defense of the E4 Pawn that's
why Magnus is not playing F4
automatically and might not play it at
all mhm that's right yeah white might be
more interested in maybe anticipating
this and preparing perhaps F3 just to be
solid in in the center indeed and rookie
7 indirectly defending the A7 pawn
something tells me that pawn is not
going to be captured I I don't know why
I'm just getting that sense you you have
a very keen sense for the position Dan
good sense of danger I was right him on
look at me he doesn't take the pawn and
then this little Bishop C8 move the
bishop is like what what is it this game
maybe even this match it's like Queens
on F1 and f8 I've seen both Bishops
return to their original squares like
these guys are playing so Cy right now
it's some sort of artificial Fisher
random game I mean how often do you even
have a queen on fa a rook not on E8 but
on E7 kind of a weird arrangement of
pieces it it seems to me like Magnus
holds the advantage in this game he has
more space he's got better control of
key Central squares and the opening that
this structure reminds me of is a bon
right that pawn on C5 Whit's Pawn on D5
and in a bon the engine often evaluates
it in White's favor but in practice it's
actually very very difficult to make
concrete progress and Magna says I'm
tired of the kg play I'm going to go E5
and I'm going to run you over in the
center totally and there's an idea which
I barely even get to talk about before I
believe it's on the board right now I
almost want to award this a double uh
exclamation mark just because of how
thematic it is Daniel Pawn takes and
then white continues Pawn to F5 and all
those black pieces that want to use the
E5 Square are looking at the pawn and
saying come on dude move out of the
and it and it does move out of the way
but he rips the Band-Aid off but he
invites White's Knight into the center
and that's the problem after Knight
takes C4 F6 is threatened D6 is
threatened the G6 Pawn is weak as well
hikaru's position is suddenly on the
verge of collapse am on I call that
technique the square clearer it's where
you push your Pawn up and vacate the
square left behind in order to put a
knight on that square Black's position
is in Dire
Straits and we are all one wondering how
you came up with that great name I'm
known for my originality that's why they
paay me the big bucks to commentate the
SEC finals and after uh E4 we
essentially have the same position
except the D6 Pawn is missing because if
White had played F5 first there would
have been a Pawn on e4 Pawn on D6
White's position is so much better with
these moves included Rook E8 and tactics
everywhere Rook takes E4 is the threat
right now yeah and the move F6 which
probably t a lot of people watching this
show right now I think it fails
tactically black can take on F6 and
after the trade the E3 Bishop is going
to hang it's actually a pretty easy line
to visualize if you look at that E3
Bishop that Bishop would love to be
anywhere but there and that's why Bishop
G5 here has to be seriously considered
by Magnus but it can be met with the
move F6 so yes the eval bar giving a big
Advantage but in practice a very hard
position to navigate accurately the
bishop slides up to F4 instead of G5
yeah and you know the double uh question
mark is showing up there Danel but it's
almost a a double question mark because
you could have done better not because
Bishop for itself was so bad Rook e
seven oh he car forgot goodness he Caro
forgot that Rook takes E8 is going to
pin the queen he drops a minor piece
yeah at first I was like wait a minute
Bishop A6 is he forgetting there's a
queen on F1 but then it was a step
further than that he knew the queen was
there but Magnus Rook takes E7 and Rook
takes E8 he is going to pull away with a
victory here especially with 10 seconds
left on the clock for hikaro after this
plunder and he resigns because A6 Falls
you can't take the queen and Magnus
strikes first after that initial draw